honestly some fairy tale they're right
here yeah not so much because Charlie
D'Amelio and chase Hudson aka little
honey have officially called it quits
yep both tick tock stars took to their
Instagram story to share the news which
came just months after they first
started hanging out yeah who's like do
you want to be like we need to be
exclusive with each other and I started
taking things point more seriously
because we started talking to each other
about how we felt we took a long time
because I first it was just like yeah
this is like fun poking jokes and a
little bit of flirting here and there
and then it really took off later in her
post to the fifteen-year-old who
recently became the most followed person
on tik-tok revealed that she decided to
post about the split since her followers
have watched their relationship from the
start adding that it hurts but
ultimately the decision was what's best
for the both of us
quote we are still friends and I would
not change that for anything I truly
have so much love for chase and wish
nothing but the best for him it makes me
so happy to see all of the great things
he has going for him he ended her post
by apologizing for taking so long to
tell their fans about the break-up
explaining I wanted to take the time to
process it for myself
breakups are tough for anyone so I'd
really rather not talk about it anymore
we were just like off in our own little
fairy land it was cute as for chase he
echoed all that writing well we will
always have love for each other we are
no longer together
he called Charlie an amazing person and
said he's beyond grateful and blessed to
have spent time with her
adding we will always be friends and she
will always hold a special place in my
heart for the rest of my life back in
February the 17 year old told et he and
Charlie were exclusive but not
officially boyfriend-girlfriend I'm
taking it as slow as humanly possible
okay before I pop the question okay but
we are very exclusive and very into each
other we took a long time is that first
it was just like yeah this is like fun
poking jokes and a little bit of
flirting here and there
and then it really took off later lately
charlie has been hanging out with 15
year old stranger things star Noah snob
who she says she met through tik toks
we're all very close like the people
that we talk to a lot and he was super
super sweet to me when I met him and it
was so much fun we had some attended and
him teaching me acting so it's just fun
he just made up a dance that went very
viral so I was really cool to see like
that feels like I hang out with Charlie
for one day and so that was super funny
to see ya but he's very sweet
[Music]